Так, трошки розкрию канал.
Боляче не буде, але зуб
може трохи нагріватися.
[Звук бормашини]
Зараз ми є в Карлівці, Донецька область.
Прийнято так казати, що це —
район Донецького аеропорта.
Тут такий найбільш...
Відомий і гучний бій,
військове протистояння з тієї сторони.
Якраз там знаходиться.
Тому таке...
Доброго дня!
GPS пише, що до центру Донецька
звідси 23 чи 24 кілометра.
Ми навіть всюди пишемо:
«Ми завжди поруч, але на крок позаду».
[сміється]
Це наш легендарний «Тризуб», з якого все почалося
і який є актуальним й сьогодні.
Дивись, ось вони такі, ти його кладеш прямо
і одну серветку витягуєш.
Ти — на видалення,
а ти ... в суботу.
Це автомобіль, який має такі можливості:
виіжджати в поле, стояти окремо...
Він може працювати повністю навіть
без електричної мережі, без каналізації
і під'єднання до чого-небудь: в полі стали і...
Тут вже стоматологічний комплекс
більш серйозний.
Тут є умови, де пацієнт в цьому кріслі
може проводити набагато більше часу.
Тут є, де відпочивати лікарю...
Тут теж давай, візьми...
— Вау!
— Це те, що з Києва, да?
— Ігор, забирай ось це...
Тут база: склад з запасними частинами,
з медикаментами, з витратними матеріалами.
Це база, куди приїжджають інженери,
які ремонтують техніку, що виходить з ладу.
Тобто, такий наш стаціонарний вузол,
логістичний центр.
[лунає звук з відео на ноутбуці]
Ми приїхали допомогти військовій системі
налагодити стоматологічну службу.
Тобто, ми, як волонтери, побачили, що йде
дуже багато замовлень на пігулки від зубного болю.
Тоді почали цікавитися, що там таке...
Пігулки пігулками, але ж вони відтерміновують
лікування, а не вирішують саму проблему.
— Я зрозумів, що туди...
— А потім сюди і щоб не забути...
[звук дрелі]
[звук бормашини]
А люди, які мають швидко все змінювати,
і ми від них очікуємо,
вони пов'язані руками і ногами на інших чиновників.
Ми нічого з цим зробити не можемо,
це загальна зміна.
Це має змінюватися на рівні Генерального штабу.
Треба змінити більш важливі напрями:
розвідка, аеророзвідка...
Те, чого не було, і навіть не було ні структури,
ні слів таких не знали в штабах...
Ти де там?
Обережно...
Так, а оце, дивись, куди ми прийшли,
можна трохи і показати...
Тут свого часу, до війни, була закрита територія і...
Священники, які мають лікувати душі,
з Московського патріархату,
тут була їхня приватна територія.
А потім, коли почалася війна у 2014 році,
в Карлівці були дуже запеклі бої.
Декілька разів вона переходила
з одних рук в інші, відбивали...
Тут загинули перші хлопці з батальйону «Донбас».
Десь з четвертої ранку до пів шостої,
до шостої стріляли,
і, по суті, це був найжорсткіший обстріл,
під який ми не потрапили,
бо знаходилися трохи далі від цього місця,
але це було дуже близько і чутно.
Там долітали до нас якісь уламки...
Для мене особисто, для наших лікарів,
після того, як ми це все побачили, почули...
Та й зараз все це видно досі...
Це просто показово, що всім цим
домовленостям з окупантами — гріш ціна.
А на пів дев'ятої ранку приходять наші пацієнти,
приїжджають планово.
І я ж — до них, бо я не очікував, що вони приїдуть,
бо сталося таке! Обстріляли!
Я до хлопців кажу: ви що, не чули, не знаєте?
Вони кажуть: в нас це кожний день,
так що нам — зуби не лікувати, не їсти, не пити?
Іноді мені здається,
що доля сама до цього підвела.
У мене є досвід, я колись служив в Збройних силах.
Ще в «тій» армії офіцером був.
Мені з військовими знаходити спільну мову просто.
До того ж був пов'язаний
зі стоматологічним бізнесом до війни.
Тобто знаю, де що береться, в кого що є,
хто може поділитися витратними матеріалами.
Розумієте, ми тут не одні, ми не кинуті,
в нас є велика спільнота.
У 70-80 роках військова стоматологія
була хірургією.
Тобто: поранення, десь прилетіло,
зуб заболів — все, забрали того зуба.
Все, на гражданці вирішуй проблеми,
немає зуба — немає проблеми.
Взагалі-то, хірургія.
Можливо, для тої армії, яка була в 70-80 роки,
коли приходили в армію служити 18-річні хлопці,
це було нормально, це було правильно.
Але зараз зовсім інші виклики,
зовсім інша армія у нас.
Камон!
[англійською]
Запрошую до джунглів!
Це джунглі!
Тут вже майже нічого не залишилось.
Оце приміщення, воно первозданне,
воно таким і було відразу після обстрілу.
Тут стеля підвісна була, ще трохи десь висіла вона,
але вже поздирали це все, повикидали.
Тут якраз, я так думаю, була трапезна,
тому що там була світломузика по верху.
[сміється]
За ці 4 роки волонтерський ресурс,
який передали на баланс Збройних сил України,
його вже багато — тобто, щоб ви розуміли...
Всі стоматологічні кабінети, до єдиного,
які є в зоні проведення ООС, —
це все волонтерська допомога.
Наприклад, це — стоматологічна установка,
10 років тому була топовою моделлю.
Є рентгенівський апарат,
який робить сучасну діагностику.
Дехто бачить це обладнання у перший раз —
перший раз приїжджає і...
Тож інструкції користувача мають
бути простими, зрозумілими.
От на автоклаві, в принципі, вся інструкція користувача тут намальована.
Не треба купу цих інструкцій, журналів якихось...
Оцей весь «совок» має бути викорінений всюди,
у всіх поліклініках і закладах.
Я, коли бачив на стоматологічних виставках,
коли йдуть офіцери, військовослужбовці,
лікарі-стоматологи.
Вони заходять і йдуть по стендах,
де стоять виробники обладнання,
дилери, які продають матеріали та інструменти.
Вони підходять:
у військовій формі, молодий хлопець...
І каже: все так прикольно, слухайте,
я військовослужбовець, військовий стоматолог...
Ну ви ж знаєте, що у нас ніякого
забезпечення немає...
Може ви б змогли якусь допомогу нам надати?
Це ганьба, капець!
Я, як колишній офіцер, це бачу...
І в мене сльози на очах!
Це має бути зовсім інакше!
Вони мають приходити,
тільки бачать, що військова форма...
Це всюди в світі так!
Найкращі стоматологи в світі!
Працюють і без світла, і без інструмента!
Працюють без пацієнтів, без світла,
без інструментів, але працюють!
Без пацієнтів вони один одного лікуватимуть!
[сміються]
Все відкрито! Так..
[Запускає електростанцію]
Все працює, ура!
І самоконтроль — це найліпший контроль,
тобто треба підказати людям: дивіться,
звертайте увагу на те-то і те-то.
І вони будуть звертати увагу,
бо зацікавлені в кінцевому результаті.
От і все!
Щоб всі були здорові, щоб їм платили гроші,
щоб приходили,
і на вулиці не ховати очі від своїх пацієнтів, а навпаки:
О, мій лікар, дивіться, добрий день!
Всі хочуть так жити, і, в принципі,
так воно і відбувається.
Взагалі-то, тут такий райский куток.
Таких озер тут дуже багато.
З тієї сторони «жирні» дачі стоять,
будівлі серйозні.
Бо Донецьк був крупний, серйозний, потужний...
Таке місто, де було дуже багато різного бізнесу, бізнесменів...
Багате містечко...
Мабуть, одне з найпотужніших в Україні до війни.
Потім прийшов «русскій мір» — ви все побачили.
Розбили...
Дивіться, яка краса! Чому б не жити там...
[cміється]